字幕: Suzu Kitamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
今日は 「数学とは何か」について
皆さんと考えたいと思います
小学校、中学、高校では
すべての生徒が数学を学びますし
もちろん皆さんも
数学を学ばれたと思いますが
「数学とは何か」について
考えられたことはあるでしょうか？
「数学は苦手」と言われる方が多い一方
「公式をたくさん覚えて計算するのが数学」
といった印象をお持ちの方も少なくありません
皆さんはどうでしょうか?
「数学とは何か」という問いに対して
すべての数学者が
一様に答えるわけではありません
しかし
「公式をたくさん覚えて計算するのが数学」
だと考える数学者はまず いません
このように考える人にとって
数学をすることは
かなり苦痛なのではないかと思います
やはり 数学の本質とかけ離れたものを
数学だと思い込むのは
数学を学ぶ上で 大きな弊害となります
そういった意味でも
数学の本質について考え 理解することには
意義があると思います
今日は 数学に関する
アインシュタインとハーディーの言葉
また 私たちは数学において
何を探求するのかについて吟味し
「数学とは何か」を考えたいと思います
アインシュタインは
「数学は論理的概念の詩である」
と言いました
私はこの表現が好きで
皆さんにも この意味を
考えていただきたいと思います
まず 「論理的概念」という言葉が示すように
数学は 論理的に厳密なものです
一方 数学のもう一つの重要な要素が
「数学は詩である」
という表現に示されています
これは 数学が創造性（想像性）に溢れるものであり
芸術的でもあることを意味しています
皆さんには
「論理的に厳密である」ということと
「想像性に溢れるものである」 ということは
相反するものに映るかもしれません
しかし数学においては この二つの要素が
高度に 互いに補い合い 高め合います
残りの時間 皆さんも
このアインシュタインの素晴らしい言葉を
実感されるのではないかと思います
では 私達は数学において何を探究するのか
について考えます
「数学は数字を探究するもの」
と思われるかもしれませんが
数学には 数字を扱わない分野もあります
もう少し普遍的なものを考えることが
数学の本質を理解する上で重要です
数学者ハーディーは
「数学者とは 画家や詩人のように
構造を作り出す者である」と述べ
「数学は構造を探究するものである」
と言いました
この言葉が示すように
様々な構造を作ったり
見出したり 使ったりするのは
数学の根幹となリます
皆さんにとって
数学でどのような構造を探究するのか
よく分からないところもあるかと思います
ここに示されている
パスカルの三角形を使って
数学で扱う構造について考え
その過程で 数学の重要な特徴を
見出したいと思います
この三角形は 様々な所に現れます
例えば 皆さんは学校で
（x＋y) ² ＝x² + 2xy + y²
と学ばれたと思いますが
その係数もこの三角形の３行目に現れます
まあ今日は
こういうことを話すのはやめましょう
驚くほど多くの構造が
この三角形には含まれており
多くの重要な数学の概念を
学ぶことができます
１つ かなり分かりやすい
構造があるのですが
皆さん見つけられますか？
おそらく 最も分かりやすいのは
「左右対称である」ということでしょう
左半分に現れる数字が
右半分に同じように現れます
後でもまた触れますが
対称性は重要な構造です
各位置で 数字がどのように
決定されているか分かりますか？
まず ［三角形の］左辺と右辺上の
数字は全て１です
その他の数字は その上の
２つの数字の和になっています
例えば ２＝１＋１
３ ＝ １ + ２
６＝３ + ３ です
この三角形は 限りなく続くものですが
このように構造を理解すると
数字を覚える必要がなく
頭の中でごく簡単な計算をしながら
この三角形を作ることができます
構造を理解し 使うことの
重要性がわかる簡単な例です
では この三角形に現れる
奇数が作る構造について考えます
最初の９行に現れる奇数
１、３、５、７等ですね —
の位置がここに白色で示されています
このように 奇数が現れる位置に着目すると
面白い構造を見つけることができます
皆さん 想像力を働かせて
128行からなる 巨大なパスカルの三角形を
頭に描いてみてください
これが９行ですから
128行もあると
かなり大きなものになるはずです
その128行に現れる奇数の位置が
ここに白で示されています
この図には 明らかに構造がありますが
皆さんはその構造を
言い表すことができますか？
まず 大きな三角形がありますが
よく見ると
その三角形が ３つの少し小さな
三角形から成り立っており
さらによく見ると
その小さな三角形の１つ１つ
例えばこの三角形が
３つの より小さい三角形から
成り立っています
これが 続いて行きますね
専門的には この構造は
「フラクタル」の一種で
全体の構造が その構成部分の
構造と同じになっており
これを「自己相似」といいます
フラクタル構造は
海岸線
植物
結晶
内臓の内壁など
自然のあらゆる所で観察できます
この「フラクタル構造」を
覚えておいてください
終わり近くに 意外なところで出てきます
きりがないのですが
数学者としては
皆さんにお見せしないと
バチが当たるような構造が
ここにありますので 紹介します
このように 三角形に斜線を引き
それぞれの斜線上にある
数字の和を求めます
最初の斜線の和は１
次の斜線の和も１
その次の斜線の和は２ですね
これを続けていくと
ここに示されている数列が現れます
これは「フィボナッチ数列」と呼ばれ
多くの数学的分析に現れる 重要な数列です
先ほどのフラクタルと同様 この数列も
自然に存在する構造を
記述するのにとても有効です
例えば このフィボナッチ数を
一辺の長さに持つ正方形を
このように並べます
とても綺麗に並びますね
なぜ このように綺麗に
正方形を並べることができるのか？
家に帰って 是非考えてみてください
これを使ってできる螺旋は
自然に存在する様々な構造
例えば 貝殻
銀河
台風などを
効果的に表すことができます
このように パスカルの三角形を
少し数学的に考察するだけでも
多くの構造を見つけることができます
もちろん 数学には
多種多様な研究対象がありますが
どの数学の分野においても
何らかの形で構造を作る 見いだす
あるいは使うことによって
物事を理解し 数学的真理を確立していきます
このことを理解することは
数学の本質を理解する上で重要です
またここで 数学の重要な特徴の
幾つかを見いだすことができます
私達は パスカルの三角形を考察していて
フラクタル、フィボナッチ数列
螺旋を見つけました
他にも 多くの構造を
見つけることができます
このように
一見何の関わりもないような
様々な概念・構造が
深い所で結びついていることが
数学においてはよくあります
そして これらの多種多様な概念・構造と
その関連性を真に理解するためには
厳密な論理的思考と
豊かな想像力の両方が必要です
いくら想像力が豊かな人でも
単に想像することによって
これらの概念が結びついていることを
認識するのは不可能でしょう
また 論理的思考だけでは
これらの概念を
発想することはできません
アインシュタインが言う
「数学は論理的概念の詩である」
ということを 実感できるの
ではないでしょうか？
またここで 数学の不思議な特徴を
見いだすことができます
それは 数学が
自然に存在する構造を記述するのに
驚くほど有効であるということです
ガリレオは
「自然という書物は
数学で書かれている」と述べ
ファインマンは
「数学を理解しないと
最も深遠な宇宙の美しさを
理解することは難しい」と述べ
またウィグナーは
「自然科学において数学は
理不尽なまでに有効である」と述べました
自然科学・工学において
数学が不可欠である所以です
では最後に 数学と美について考えます
先ほど紹介した数学者ハーディーは
「数学の概念を評価する際に
最初に吟味するべき点は
その概念が美しいかどうかである」とも述べ
「醜い数学が存在する余地はない」
とも述べました
ここに 数学の本質において
不可欠な要素である
「美の探究」が言い表されています
このことについて考えます
まず 「美」自体について
考えることが必要です
皆さんは どういったものを
「美しい」と思われますか？
美しいと思うものを想像してみてください
富士山は 日本人にとって
特別な存在だと思いますが
あの山を見て なぜ私達は
「美しい」と思うのでしょうか？
美しいですよね？
明らかな特徴として
この山は どの角度から見ても
ほぼ 左右対称です
数学的にはこれは
中心軸に関する「回転対称性」
として表すことができます
また山の輪郭がとても滑らかですが
これは数学的には
曲線を表す関数とその微分可能性に
よって表すことができます
少し難しい専門用語が並びましたが
これらは 先ほど考察した
数学において探究する構造です
これらの特徴・概念は
美と結びついているのでしょうか？
近年 我々の審美眼に関する
様々な科学的研究が行われており
数学と美の関わりも 解明されつつあります
ある研究では
同程度のデータ量を持つ画像の中で
「美しい」と認識された画像の
データ圧縮性が高いことが示されました
このことについて考えます
まず データが圧縮できるということは
データを小さくできるということです
先ほど考察した
パスカルの三角形は 左右対称で
左半分に現れる数字が
右半分に同じように現れます
したがって この三角形を作るのに
すべての数字・データが必要ではなく
左半分にあるものだけで十分です
左半分を写して それを反転させて
右に写せば作れるからです
この場合 元のデータが
約半分に圧縮できることになり
パスカルの三角形は
高いデータ圧縮性を持つことになります
これは 富士山の画像にも
当てはまることです
富士山の左半分を写して
それを反転させて右に写せば
本物とほぼ変わらない
富士山の写真を作ることができます
よって 富士山の画像の
データ圧縮性も高いと言え
このような画像が「美しい」と
認識されることが研究で示されました
この写真で面白いのは
富士山が湖に写っていて
上下対称にもなっていますね
美しさが増していると思いませんか？
では 「美しい」と認識される画像の
データ圧縮性が高いことが示されたのですが
一般に どのような画像が
高いデータ圧縮性を持つのでしょうか？
先ほどの簡単な例からもわかるように
画像に数学的構造がある場合
そのデータ圧縮性は高くなります
これは 先ほど述べた研究において
「美しい」と認識された画像の例です
この顔は
ある数学的構造を用いて
非常に効率よく描かれており
データ圧縮性がとても高いのですが
どのような数学的構造が
使われていると思いますか？
どうでしょう？
実は先ほど この構造を見ていたのですけどね
ここでは フラクタルが使われています
このことを考えると
私達が数学において
探究するもの 「構造」は
「私達にが『美しい』と思うもの
またはそれに貢献するものである」
と言うこともできます
近年行われた脳研究も このことを示唆します
この図に緑で示されている脳の部位
「内側眼窩前頭皮質」は
「美しい」と認識される
風景・絵画・音楽などに
反応することで知られていたのですが
数学的概念・構造に対しても
同様に活性化することが分かりました
我々の脳にとって
数学で探究する「美」は
自然や芸術における
「美」と共通するところがあります
時間となりましたが
「数学は 論理的概念の詩である」
「数学者は 構造を作り出す者である」
「私達は数学において
『美しい』ものを探究する」
といった数学の本質的な特徴は
おそらく皆さんにとって
意外だったのではないでしょうか？
また私達が 何を「美しい」
と思うのかについて
新たな側面を 見出して
いただけたのではないでしょうか？
これから 何か美しいものを見た時
皆さんは数学のことを
考えられるかもしれません
もしかしたら
それは 大きな変化ではないでしょうか？
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）